this video uses three examples from the
chicken genome to illustrate common uses
of cloned placement data the first is
find genomic clones that contain a gene
of interest then use clone placements to
recognize a genomic region with
potential miss assembly and finally use
clone placements to recognize potential
structural variations a companion video
that focuses on clone FTP content is
linked at the end of this video very
briefly clone placements are created by
aligning end and insert sequences on
genome assemblies annotated at NCBI to
generate a clone placement for n
sequences both ends forward and reverse
must be placed on the same assembly
molecule for the first example let's
find clone placements in the region of
the chicken wdr 3 gene I'm starting in
the genome data viewer but if you happen
to be in a gene record you could link
from there to the same gdb display that
we are about to see I'll select the
previous chicken assembly Gallus Gallus
5.0 but that is simply because our three
examples better illustrate the utility
of clone placements in that particular
assembly you might want to have a look
at the wdr 3 gene region in the updated
assembly to see how it has improved to
get to the region of the wdr 3 gene use
the search box on the left we now see
the wdr 3 gene model the next step is to
add tracks for clone placements from the
tracks menu mouse over ncbi recommended
track sets then select assemblies
support this adds a predefined group of
tracks including clone placements for
the 3 libraries with the largest number
of placements clones with unique
concordant placements are displayed as
solid blue lines unique discordant
clones display as a solid red line and
multiple discordant clones display as
dotted red line this clone also has a
gray background indicating that not all
n sequence is associated with the clone
support this placement if you want to do
you
other clone placement tracks in the
genomic clone set
and notice that you can upload other
data such as one of the GFF files on the
clone ftp site okay we're now ready to
identify good clones for the WD r3 Jean
I'll adjust the zoom a bit in order to
better see the assembly gap and I'll
also add a marker for the gap region
and I'll need to scroll down to see the
clone tracks now you see that the CH 261
library includes several blue clones
those with unique concordant placements
that contain this assembly gap so we've
met our first goal of finding genomic
clones for a gene of interest let's move
on to the second example a quick look at
using clone placements to assess the
quality of an assembly in this case to
recognize a genomic region with
potential miss assembly I've moved over
to chicken chromosome Z and we see a
dramatic change in placements from
unique concordant to discordant at about
72 mega bases this change occurs in all
three libraries indicating a likely miss
assembly in the region the DNA source
for this 5.0 assembly is the same as in
the CH 261 library but different in the
two other libraries further suggesting a
miss assembly here in the final example
we look at clone placements that
indicate possible structural variation
I've moved over to chromosome 21 and
here we see a few smaller regions in the
je AC and jad libraries with placements
of both concordant and discordant clones
this mixture is suggestive of structural
variation but additional analyses are
needed to verify this including closer
evaluation of boundaries and possibly
sequencing of clones to narrow down
locations notice that the end clones
from the CH 261 library have only
concordant placements in these regions
remember that the source sequence for CH
261 is different from the other two
leaving open the possibility of genomic
variation in these regions that
concludes this tutorial please use the
support center link found on most ncbi
pages for your questions and feedback we
would love to hear from you